[Música]
y repasamos la economía mundial en torno
a esta guerra ya está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón dan y bienvenida
nuevamente hablamos del precio del
petróleo que toco sus peores niveles
desde la crisis de 2008 pues de raúl por
lo menos el precio del petróleo brent
que es el que se entrega en el mar del
norte en europa pues se ha estabilizado
en torno a los 120 dólares un poco más
en londres pero llegó incluso a superar
los 130 dólares que es un máximo desde
la crisis financiera de 2008 este
repunte se produce después de que eeuu
dijera el fin de semana que analiza con
la unión europea la posibilidad de
prohibir la importación de petróleo ruso
inclusive el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski pidió hoy un boicot
en ese sentido y el llamado ya lo
atendió lituania cuyo ministro de
exteriores dijo que no se puede pagar el
petróleo con la sangre de los ucranianos
y con todo este invierno en europa
daniela de gas natural está en máximos
históricos bueno hay que decir que la
unión europea le compra el 40 por ciento
de su gas a rusia
y menores flujos de envío pues han
llevado a su cotización a valores nunca
antes vistos justo en momentos en los
que como usted dice los ciudadanos más
demandan de calefacciones con el
invierno todavía presente un ejemplo es
que hace un año un megavatio hora de gas
natural ésta es una medida costaba 16
tres euros hoy él cuesta
335 euros esto es 20 veces más de lo que
hace un año escuchemos el análisis
business one tenemos dos problemas los
consumidores están sufriendo una pérdida
de poder adquisitivo y debido al aumento
de los precios y las empresas están
haciendo menos negocios con rusia todo
esto junto puede llevar a que la
economía entre en recesión o al menos
que haya una inflación fuerte con temas
como la seguridad energética los precios
de la energía y la inflación lo que
enfrentamos este año es una catástrofe y
los bancos centrales no saben qué hacer
y catástrofe también fue como abrieron
las bolsas desplomadas hoy daniela claro
que sí lo hicieron primero las bolsas
asiáticas que son los que primero
cierran hong kong cayó a mínimos en
cinco años por los altos precios del
crudo y las acciones europeas operan en
mínimos de un año pero también en otros
indicadores decimos que el trigo están
máximos de 14 años y los precios del
níquel en londres se dispararon hasta un
30,7 por ciento solamente el lunes
solamente el lunes y algunas de las
monedas de américa latina se están
fortaleciendo debido a toda esta guerra
daniela claro al tiempo que el rublo cae
a mínimos históricos fue antes de ahora
un rublo se compra con un centavo de
dólar menos de un centavo de dólar pues
las monedas de países emergentes están
ganando terreno frente al dólar una
situación que ha beneficiado sobre todo
a países de américa latina el analista
jorge enrique garcía castro nos explica
por qué
nuestro presentar en las exportaciones
de las economías de latinoamérica
depende de las materias primas por
ejemplo en el caso de colombia alrededor
del 45 por ciento del total exportado
corresponde a petróleo el incremento tan
significativo que hemos evidenciado
recientemente en el precio de las
materias primas genera en el corto plazo
una sobreoferta de dólares en estos
mercados de latinoamérica y eso genera a
su vez en ese corto plazo una
apreciación de estas divisas de latam
con respecto al dólar estadounidense
pero también se crea mayor inflación
como un aumento por ejemplo en el precio
de la gasolina el gobierno de méxico
anunció que podría aumentar inclusive
los subsidios a los combustibles de ser
necesario por estos altos precios y
debido la guerra en rusia danny hay
muchas empresas que se van pero hay
otras pocas que se quedan bueno le voy a
decir cuáles se quedan en mcdonald's
pepsico y ahora unique lo que es una
firma japonesa con 49 tiendas en este
país y es que el director ejecutivo de
su casa matriz dijo que la ropa es de
primera necesidad y que los rusos tienen
el mismo derecho que todo el resto del
mundo a comprarla pero los gobiernos si
siguen presionando nueva zelanda
presentará un proyecto de ley que le
permitirá congelar los activos rusos
evitar que personas muevan su dinero
vaya allí para escapar de los castigos
impuestos por occidente y bloquear
también el ingreso de superyates y
barcos entre otras lujos de los magnates
allegados al kremlin por su parte corea
del sur corea del sur prohibir a las
transacciones con el banco central de
rusia danny ahora se cifra el día mira
es bien interesante 156 millones de
dólares esto ha incautado desde el
viernes del gobierno italiano en yates y
mansiones de magnates rusos en sus
destinos más lujosos como cerdeña costa
de liguria y el lago como bueno daniela
más sanciones más incautaciones a estos
oligarcas rusos también lo vamos a
analizar uno de estos días de esta
semana en directo américa gracias por
toda la información mañana nos vemos con
más vamos directo